[Music]
on this wednesday night
new problems for old schools
the anxiety in the air about ventilation
systems
systems might um not be up to par
you know i have a classroom has no
windows as bc
announces a gradual return to class the
democrats new duo
kamala knows how to govern she knows how
to make the hard calls
the monumental magnitude of joe biden
choosing kamala harris as his running
mate
they were definitely in a new era and
deadly derailment
[Music]
a rare tragedy in rural scotland
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser good evening and thank you
for joining us
while teachers shuffle around desks
rework timetables and stock up on masks
ahead of september
there is one big part of the back to
school conversation which educators
are worried about ventilation in toronto
a mock
setup showing what 35 kids in a class
would look like
difficulty distancing is one thing but
air circulation is another
especially inside and especially in
older schools that lack
proper ventilation systems right now
windows and doors can be kept open but
teachers worry
about what happens in the winter heather
urex west reports on the issue
causing concern from coast to coast to
coast
with just weeks to go until his kids
head to class
david stalker is worried as a parent you
have
all the same concerns how do you keep
the kids separate enough
that they don't get sick themselves but
also bring
sickness back into families he worries
his children and students won't be able
to physically distance in crowded
classrooms
but depending on the age of the school
there could be additional risks
that would be the one concern is that
older buildings
might have been designed to a different
standard but also
if they're not maintained all that well
the hvac or the heating ventilation air
conditioning systems might
not be up to par the virus is spread by
droplets that can linger in the room if
air is not properly circulated
it's why health officials have
recommended we spend time with others
outside when possible
opening doors and windows can help get
air moving
but in many canadian classrooms that's
just not possible
we know that that's the case in many
many schools in some cases
windows are literally painted shut and
cannot be opened my drama room
for instance in my classroom at my
school has no windows in it because it
is
it's a drama space right and so that
would be a concern if i had students in
there
it's why advocates are calling on school
districts to make sure
their facilities are ready the funding
given to maintain
systems in schools is very low so the
work probably hasn't been
done as well as it could be so i'd be
very concerned as the weather gets
cooler and people move indoors
calgary's board of education says it's
currently reviewing the ventilation
systems at its facilities across the
city
one more item on a long list of things
to do
to prepare for classes amid covid 19.
heather urex west global news calgary
so you can understand why parents are
agonizing over whether or not to send
their children back to class
a top child psychiatrist at bc
children's hospital says
when safety is on the line school is
less important
it's a perspective that runs contrary to
official public health guidelines in
that province
today officials there revealed students
will be returning to classrooms
two days later than originally planned
catherine erkhardt is following the
developments for us catherine
tell us about the gradual restart to
schooling there
that's right well after weeks of
pressure from the opposition from
teachers
and from parents we're finally learning
when kids
in bc will be returning to the classroom
bc's education minister announcing today
that while teachers will return on
september the 8th
kids won't go back until two days later
on the 10th
why the two-day delay well it's also
that teachers can get used to the new
safety protocols
before kids are back on site for some
parents the delay of course will bring
some child care challenges but most are
fully embracing any and all efforts
to keep our kids safe efforts that could
even include more
outdoor learning one size does not fit
all we all understand that
but we also understand that it's
fundamental to
re-establishing a normalcy within our
communities
that we have safe places for our kids to
be
so they can learn and grow and socialize
and do all the wonderful things
that children do another question in
recent weeks has been the use of
masks bc's education minister now saying
that masks
will play a significant role in the
return to school
however they will not be required in the
classroom
only when physical distancing cannot be
maintained
it's all part of the new normal as kids
here in bc
return to school back to you thanks
catherine
biden harris 2020 has begun the
presumptive democratic presidential
running mates appeared together for the
very first time
joe biden saying senator kamala harris
will show young girls especially
black and brown girls who feel
overlooked that they too can one day
lead the country
but as jennifer johnson reports
president donald trump true to form
is already making personal attacks
against biden's historic pick
for vp the biden harris team has made it
official
launching their bid for the white house
the democratic ticket says they want to
restore the soul of the nation
kamala as you all know is smart
she's tough she's experienced
she's a proven fighter for the backbone
of this country
the middle class we don't have to accept
the failed government of donald trump
and mike pence
in just 83 days we have a chance
to choose a better future
for our country senator kamala harris
the daughter of a jamaican economist
and a cancer researcher from india is
the first black and first asian american
nominee
for vice president it is in a sense the
american story immigrants who come here
who work hard who raised their two
daughters to
think that there were no limits to what
they could achieve i think that's a
story we will all look up to
when you commit despite harris clashing
with biden over a senate record on race
segregation
during the democratic presidential
debates and that little girl
was me the two men defenses many
political experts and voters believe
she's the person who can help biden win
in november
she lifts up so many communities and and
so many women when i heard it i
literally had to pull the car over and i
cried
it was just you know such such a huge
historic
thing that's happened judge u.s
president donald trump has often
criticized the first term senator
especially after her intense questioning
of judge brett kavanaugh
during his supreme court nomination
hearings it was
just a horrible thing the way she was
the way she treated
now justice kavanaugh and i won't forget
that soon
harris spent grades 7 through 11 in
montreal where her mother taught at
mcgill university
she has taken on big banks as
california's attorney general
and criminal justice reform in the u.s
senate now her sites are set on the
white house
and if elected harris would become
america's first
female vice president jennifer johnson
global news
washington there is another woman making
waves in the 2020 election race but for
very different reasons than harris her
name is marjorie taylor greene
and she's a vocal proponent of the far
right conspiracy theory movement
they are terrified because i'm going to
be their worst nightmare
queen won the republican nomination in
georgia's congressional primary last
night
and she stands a good chance of winning
her staunchly conservative district come
november
she's known for making racist
anti-semitic and islamophobic remarks
green also promotes q anon a baseless
conspiracy theory that alleges a deep
state plot
against president trump to our nation's
capital prime minister justin trudeau
was not
at a rare summer sitting at the house of
commons in ottawa today
he's on vacation and the black quebecois
leader wants him gone
for good yves haswell issued a public
ultimatum saying he will try to trigger
a fall election
if the prime minister his chief of staff
and his finance minister
don't resign over the we charity student
grant controversy
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stephenson joins us now with more
mercedes this is
a lot of talk but how likely is it to
happen
it is pharah it's a lot of political
bluster from the bq leader today
but the threat of an election is mostly
just that an
empty threat unless he can find other
opposition parties
that back the block before we dive into
how likely that is to happen
take a quick listen to what the bq
leader told reporters this morning
our point is that as one important
voice for quebec we observe that this
government might not be
worthy of our trust anymore
now other opposition parties have been
critical as well but in order to trigger
an actual
election and bring down the minority
liberal government the bq will need them
to vote against the government
here's the math on how that could work
take a look at the house of commons the
liberals have 156 seats in the house
the conservatives are probably the most
likely opposition party to back the
block if they went ahead
but even if you combine those two party
seats you still only have
153 mps that's not enough to topple the
government
you'd need four more mps from other
parties to be on side to bring down the
liberals
and even if the conservatives aren't a
sure thing and they're not at this point
because they don't have a leader we
talked to aaron o'toole's campaign
leslie lewis's campaign and peter
mckay's campaign
they all told global news that their
candidates are focused on winning the
leadership race right now
before they think about other pools that
puts the ndp into the power player seat
but they've got low polling and low
fundraising lately which means
they're unlikely to trigger an election
we don't think it's an appropriate thing
right now
to be trying to position for an election
when we're in a pandemic
people need help and we've been
successful so far
in bringing about our vision for a more
compassionate response to kobe 19.
now the green party told global news
they also believe an election during a
pandemic would be irresponsible
and it's unlikely that the two
independents former liberals jody wilson
raybould and marwan tabara
would be the ones to bring down the
government so while there's lots of
shouting about criticism for
accountability
and what justin trudeau must and must
not do it doesn't seem there's a lot of
political will
to take the risk of going to the polls
all right mercedes let's go back to the
conservatives for a second because the
leader andrew scheer rose in the house
of commons today and
this is likely his last time as
opposition leader
what was that moment like a little
unceremonious i mean typically when you
have a leader stepping down you have a
lot more people getting up and giving
speeches but this was not a typical day
in any way
we're not normally sitting here in the
middle of august with the house sitting
we could still hear more from andrew
scheer but it won't be in the house
as he steps down and we wait to find out
who the next conservative leader is
farah mercedes stevenson in ottawa thank
you
to canada's busiest highway next the 401
where a flying wheel
hit a car and killed the 24 year old
driver
police say a pickup truck was towing a
trailer during the morning rush hour
when a tire flew
off the trailer smashed into the car
that was traveling in the opposite
direction
ontario police investigate about 150
wheel separation incidents
every year in the greater toronto area
a deadly train ride in europe coming up
the trip along scotland's
scenic countryside that turned tragic
[Music]
at least three people are dead after a
passenger train derailed in northeast
scotland and caught fire
it jumped the tracks in a hilly area
with one car tumbling down an embankment
rescue efforts were hampered by the
street steep terrain and dense woods
the train's driver is believed to be
among those killed
six others were hospitalized with
non-life-threatening injuries
the suspected cause of the derailment is
a landslide
caused by heavy rains there
efforts to stop an environmental
disaster off mauritius may be at a
turning point
the island nation's prime minister says
most of the fuel has now been removed
from a stranded
tanker that struck a coral reef in late
july
it's believed as much as 1 000 tons of
oil has already spilled from the vessel
since it began cracking last week new
satellite images show the extent of the
spill
as more oil washes onto the ecologically
sensitive coastline
the government intends to seek financial
compensation from the carrier's
japanese owners beirut's port has
partially reopened
just over a week after the deadly
explosion there
lebanon's caretaker economy minister
says 12 out of
16 cranes are now operating to secure
goods for local markets
container shipping is crucial to the
country because lebanon
imports nearly 85 percent of its food
work is underway at the port to clean
out the destruction left behind by the
blast
at least 170 people were killed and more
than six thousand
injured one a warehouse filled with
ammonium nitrate caught fire
last week in belarus
women are rallying in the capital to
protest a brutal police crackdown
that left hundreds injured and thousands
detained
the protest began three days ago
challenging election results that extend
the 26-year rule of the country's
authoritarian leader
police responded with unusual force
using tear gas
stun grenades water cannons and rubber
bullets
but women are now joining forces to
protest as officers
are more hesitant to use force against
them
cold case still ahead the suspected
source of new zealand's
latest covid19 outbreak
new zealand's largest city auckland is
back in full lockdown
the restrictions were brought in today
after the country recorded four new
cases of covid 19.
new zealand had gone 102 days without
recording a locally transmitted case
contact tracing is currently underway
but as crystal commansing explains
the source of the outbreak has baffled
health officials
we know how to beat this but we also
know we don't need to look far
to see what it can mean if we don't get
on top of it we have a plan
and now is the time to follow it the
plan is simple
get tested use the track and trace app
and stay
home at noon wednesday auckland went
back into lockdown
probably is the right decision yes i
think we should
until we sort out how far it's spread in
the community
the new cases include a family of four
one of them
works for a cold storage company new
zealand health officials are looking at
frozen freight as a
possible transmission route according to
the british columbia center for disease
control
similar coronaviruses have been shown to
survive in refrigerators and freezers
for weeks and it's likely the new virus
can
also persist in cold environments we do
know the virus is spread through
droplets of an infected person
if another individual comes in contact
with those droplets or an
infected surface they can become ill
there are also an additional
four probable cases who are people with
symptoms
linked to the four community-based cases
we talked about last night
and earlier this morning all of these
probable cases are awaiting test results
until this week life had pretty much
gone back to normal
the country has just over 1200 covet 19
infections
new zealand has been able to keep case
numbers in check
through aggressive virus elimination
measures
very worried hopefully things will be
okay but
yeah very glad that the government has
moved quickly it's the right thing to do
the lockdown for roughly 1 million
people will be in place
until friday when the country's
resurgence plan
will be reassessed crystal gomansen
global news london
meantime nearby australia has recorded
its deadliest day since the pandemic
began
21 deaths were reported in the last 24
hours and all of them happened
in the hard-hit state of victoria the
country has also recorded its biggest
daily rise in coven 19 infections in
three days
with more than 400 new confirmed cases
the bulk of them are linked to an
outbreak in melbourne
australia's second largest city remains
under a strict lockdown
if you thought outdoor concerts were a
thing of the past take a look at this
the first large-scale physically
distanced concert happened in the united
kingdom
yesterday british musician sam fender
headlined
500 platforms were positioned two meters
apart to ensure fans can enjoy live
music
and adhere to safety guidelines also
perfect for those who feel anxious in
large crowds
only five people were allowed in each
penndoth area
when biden picked harris next will this
presidential pair make history
or repeat it
in november americans may elect the
first female vice president of the
united states
we've been here before the excitement
the build up the genuine belief
that history for women could be made but
life had other plans our eric sorensen
was at
both national conventions that nominated
the last two female vice presidential
nominees
he says this time's different walter
mondale beat
joe biden to the punch by 36 years i
looked
for the best vice president
and i found her in jerry ferraro
geraldine ferraro was hailed as a
breakthrough in american politics
the first woman on the presidential
ticket of a major u.s party
the issue is not
what america can do for women
but what women can do for america
it was exciting and bold but america
wasn't ready
mondale ferraro suffered an historic
drubbing by the incumbent ticket
ronald reagan and george bush governor
sarah palin 24 years later just the
second woman vp
nominee they say the difference between
a hockey mom and a pit bull
lipstick again the excitement was real
but once more
short-lived in hindsight mondale and
mccain had each thrown caution to the
winds
putting a woman on the ticket to
energize flagging campaigns that seemed
destined to lose
this is different joe biden was and is
in a strong position to win
adding kamala harris a woman of color is
not the gamble it once would have been
it's not a sarah palin gender pick
it is a substantive candidate who will
partner with biden
it will be historic because history has
been harsh towards women in u.s
presidential politics
seldom seen never victorious there have
been
48 u.s vice presidents look at all these
vice presidents of the past
is there one black person no is there
one
woman who served as vice president no
and the whole history of the vice
presidency
doesn't mirror our glorious diversity to
replenish
such a nasty one and attitudes of sexism
still exist
hillary clinton faced them and so will
kamala harris
she was nasty to a level that was just
a horrible thing but the polls suggest
2020 is a turning point
biden at 77 may be a one-term president
paving the way for more history to be
made
not only did he pick a vice presidential
nominee but he probably also picked the
front-runner for the 2024
democratic nomination and that it's a
woman of color is
is a big deal they were definitely in a
new era a new era in american politics
it's been a long time in coming eric
sorenson global news
and that's global national for this
wednesday i'm farah nasser
tonight's your canada is this shot of
the hammocks
along the halifax waterfront if you'd
like to share your canada with us
email your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks so much for watching until
tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other have a good night
you